I like the Jim Carrey one yeah I think
that one's fun the most photographed
star of the night the Fiji water girl
you must have heard about her by now she
captivated the Internet by meticulously
photo buying pretty much every single
celeb at the Golden Globes red-carpet on
Sunday night and while she became a
viral sensation within hours not
everyone was abused Jamie Lee Curtis
certified Queen badass Laurie Strode
herself was not thrilled to be
photobombed by Fiji water girl on
Instagram she wrote I specifically moved
away from the blatant promotions by Fiji
and moet where young women with their
trays filled with their wares stood near
a designated camera I knew why there was
a photographer poised there and I moved
away as I said out loud that I didn't
want to be doing advertising for either
clearly this ankle shows that I moved
from her being behind me and yet from
the side it still happens the sponsors
of events need to get permission from
people when they get them to take their
picture next to products so on one hand
the Fiji campaign clearly worked this
girl's just doing her job a lot of
people thought it was super funny we're
still talking about it but to Jamie's
point
so let's weren't exactly given the
option here I've been reading tweets
about this all morning people are pretty
divided so I'm curious to hear your
thoughts
I don't think Jamie is criticizing the
Fiji water girl as much as she's just
criticizing not wanting to advertise
something she doesn't actively endorsed
and I think that's a fair point but
let's hear from the other side of things
Fiji water girl herself her name is
Kenneth Cuthbert she joined us in the et
live studio to explain her side of just
how she ended up everywhere Wow I don't
know exactly okay so how much of the
photobombing was on purpose or how much
was accidental well there are a lot of K
I'm sure you guys have been there there
are a lot of cameras at every single
angle it doesn't matter where you stand
you're in somebody's way and Fiji has
their own photographer but they
encouraged us just to be ourselves have
fun hydrate the stars keep everybody
well hydrated and you just sometimes end
up in the crossfire
you ended up in the crossfire
well that's the thing is like we were
watching the show we were talking about
and over the course the evening and of
course you just kept popping up and
popping up and everyone says who's this
girl who's this girl when did you first
know that this was becoming a thing I
think I was the last to find out I was I
didn't have my phone on me it was still
working my shift and right as the last
stragglers were heading into the Golden
Globes ceremony people were busting out
their phones and like do you know you're
going viral and I thought they meant
like Fiji and the Fiji girls I didn't
know they meant me specifically I went
on break and check my phone and was just
bombarded by what was going on so funny
so there's both sides I want to know
what you guys think do you have any hot
Fiji water girl takes on that ash
Carlson and until next time we've got
you covered
[Music]